für den dsds-gewinner Pietro Lombardi
haben wir uns etwas ganz besonderes
ausgedacht um in das eine oder andere
Geheimnis zu entlocken
wie wird er reagieren wenn er einen
Freund Riff der Prototyp Ausland waren
überhaupt nicht von DSDS mitbekommen
hat das werdet ihr gleich sehen es ist
ja schon eine gute alte Tradition bei
uns dass die DSDS
Gewinner sich bei uns quasi die Griechin
die Hand geben jedes Jahr seit Thomas
Godoj waren sie alle bei Clixoom und
Biedermann Body kommt wieder pünktlich
zur Veröffentlichung seines neuen
Albums
ich sage
die Lage ist ja immer bei dir beim l4
auch wenn Vettel bisher bekommen das ist
immer Klasse weil um
die werden gerne gesehen die Gewinner
von DSDS ich weiß nicht warum Bertone
ist besonders beliebt habe ich
festgestellt
Mainz denkste
ja ich habe es gelesen du hast alle
Rekorde gebrochen innerhalb von 26
Stunden hat rund zwanzigtausend Down
Moses hat zwar noch nicht so gegeben
Thailands sein sehr schönes Gefühl
also ich habe das selber nie erwartet
Zungen
das Zeug zum bisher letzten mal
und das Video habe ich jetzt auch noch
gehört
hatte in Deutschland den Lady Gaga
Rekord gebrochen und auch mehr runter
geladen worden in kürzester Zeit als
Lady Gaga
oder
Platz zwölf Fenster kannst du mir das
erklären
der Halbleiter man sich selber Nadal
muss man die die
Ritler sehen Fragen warum sie da drauf
klicken weil
Bild für mich ist es so so so
nur diese Orchester
und da hat man überlegt bald es gibt
gewisse ist
Monat vor Monaten da war ich auch nicht
der einzige
um es gibt also auf Google so gut
gelungen dass die meisten Produkte sind
plötzlich tauchte sein Name auf
Dollar wer ist das denn
und ich habe damit nicht die erste Group
Treffpunkt ist das denn die SGS
Teilnehmern am Start
sofort wird wittert
ich kenne den Sieger von DSDS Pietro
Lombardi
Berggruen hatte recht
weltweit das einzige sofort bis zum 4
Anfahrt an der beliebteste
offensichtlich gewesen
mal ganz weit vorne
ja man das
manchmal kann man Chilcott zu Aussagen
ihrer Geldbörse wo ich bin
hat irgendjemand über die diskutiert
warum ist so trifft
also machte man so die Kalender durch
die Banken die dann alle einen Steinwurf
nötig sei oder du zusammen der bei
einer Probe
jeder hat seinen eigenen Charakter hat
jeder Mensch ist anders ja
dabei hatte das jüngste Kind
doch und Dichter trifft warum du bist
vielleicht weil die
die Neusserin vergessen dass sich hier
so bin wie ich bin ich sehr
bestimmte Dienste dies dass die Winter
wesentlich verändern sich dann so ich
stehe fest dass es wie du und du
und für mich ist und dieses gewinnen
oder Maler Lackierer des Saales
für mich sind menschlich und das ist
einfach
offen ehrlich
das auch ich will man kein Spiel Franz
warten spielt eine Rolle
ich bin ein Freund von dir
etwa sechs Monate in Australia
Ackermann hat das alles nicht
mitbekommen
Partner und entriss er jetzt
richtig toll was ist denn passiert
bleibt hier
Presseberichte über die sind jetzt
direkt an zum 8 erst bei DSDS mitgemacht
um
sie soll das
ja also ich haben wollte mal schauen
weil ich da komme ich nochmal humorig
Siegenthaler nicht wollt von Regie
Manuel Fumic gegen und jagen sie mit dem
Sieger Eldar Hasic tierische Angst
gehabt dass der Politthriller strikt ab
anstatt aus dem App Store auf dem war
natürlich will man wieder vollzählig
ist das erste
den ersten Traum Bord was denkst du dir
wenn Hitzfeld ich bin was sagt er und
nennt RK NDR blamiert nicht so dass alle
mich auslachen oder etwas gutes und das
was gutes Gott sei dank
Mauch musste gar nicht das 2
das Ambitionen in die Richtung
gleich im
wie du weißt dass mein guter Freund
für den bietet sich derzeit zwei Jahren
ja er hat hohe und lernen dann habe ich
mir einfach gelagerten Fällen
es wird interessant ist dass Max
daher habe ich vor kurzem auch nicht
gedacht aber ich habs für Handwerker
abgesagt werden
ich muss man mal Angst überwinden und
Marvon endlich die professionelle Jury
gehen und
ja nichts
okay aber ich dachte immer produziert
und liefert
ordentlich sehr gut jetzt hat das sehr
ordentlich ja Dr es ist ja so nie geben
Sänger und man weiß ja nicht wie lange
das hält gesund
also ist also mein guter Freund ja
für Bayern wäre an sich glaubt dann
werden wir alle zusammen
kennst du was Sandra massereichen
und
ja man muss nur daran glauben wenn man
andere Sache überhaupt dann kann man es
auch schaffen
und 80
also am Anfang hat sie selbst Zweifel
gehabt aber
irgendwie Prozent der Zeitzer kann man
merkt Kraft getan mehr Selbstbewusstsein
und dann
also jetzt ist es auf dem vom ein Traum
und wenig
jetzt Leben wir St
meine Kinder überhaupt noch mal
miteinander telefoniert Albers
ausgesetzt auf jeden Fall Kinder» so
nähern und wenn du machst einfach war
auf dem Aufzug vom Mittwoch mehrheitlich
staatliche Eigentümer Projekt wollen
und wer
ich würde mich freuen wenn du kommst es
überwacht immer mehr zu tun haben auf
jeden Fall ihr bislang bester Freund
Prozent der Bund sie finde ich mir das
vorstellen dass hiv-infizierte irre
viele Shows gemacht um Coaching und den
Tod
da wobei ich habe ich ein paar
Ausschnitte gesehen dass wir eine echte
Prozent was ich auch dir angetan habe
nichts zu ergänzen
Prozent der Wagen in dem Bericht solange
geben wie Gekas
was er nicht mag mag Zeit her
allmählich wird noch nie gemacht Meyer
also es stimmt schon er arbeitete immer
ein Mensch
das macht ein Mensch aus seiner Feder
hat also ein perfekter Mix ein guter
Mensch bin ich mehr zu perfekt zu sein
ich habe meine Fehler im Text lernen
wenn ich bin ich natürlich kann
man vergisst ja den Tätern
ich sag dann bei mir ist es so komisch
wenn ich den Text vergessen
dann will ich Leben zeigen dass ich den
Text hat vergessen habe okay
und ja also ich hin
m wenn man Fehler gemacht dann lernt man
daraus
Texte gut gelernt rb7 feminin Kopf
geblieben
daraus habe ich gelernt Abends Mellon
Maryland nahe als Konsequenz der neue
Skills es geht doch was ist das für ein
Gefühl der ist
auf der Bühne zu stehen und nicht mehr
fünf Arbeitnehmern oder
30 Mann sondern
3 was ihm gefiel es ist ein Genuss Chips
nee nee also es ist ein Spaß macht sagt
Baumann keine Angst haben und
das wichtige ist Musiker
ist samt Musik singen aber
so viel Spaß so verbunden und einfach
eine Sprache bringen hast dann ist es
gut wenn du Abends saßen
es ist nicht gut
und du hast keine Angst
ich habe keine Angst mehr nicht alle ab
obwohl wir das vorher passiert ist der
Läufer keine Angst meine Zeit nicht
die Stockbetten ganzen Text viele haben
mich stark gemacht so
ich wollte den Leuten zeigen
Vivendi stiegen um bei diesen Text
vergisst
ob der jetzt muss ich muss
ich muss es sein nun bin ich nicht
Weisser
so was wie mich Film für mich weil die
e-biker was solls von mir denken weil
Ende Mai akzeptiert mich so wie ich bin
oder nicht
aber es braucht also mein eigenes so
kann man eigentlich so kommen
du musst in Pakistan es ist leichter und
so kann sich dann selbst sondern sind
weiter sinken
dann okay
mein Text kann nicht mehr also
nach München gerüstet in das zu
schaffen auf dem Rasen Red
Prozent also die Hagener Mutter bis 20
mal Zeit zum lernen die Zeit haben wir
einige leichte und für eine Woche
Miller ist
am Samstag sogar noch gelernt von
morgens bis
Kunst oder schauen
am Barren zu tun
und dies ist einer von ihnen habe ich
festgestellt habe ich meine Freunde
Asbest führt genau
und wie ist das
das ist sehr schön ich meine
wenn man Prozent Lehmann hat den Mann
alles ist denkbar
von dem Mann geliebt werden ist
natürlich ein schönes Gefühl als ob
alle freuen
deshalb wolle er das
das ist schon Klasse noch nicht
eröffnet haben
Barcelona
und die sagten 60 gut fand ich auch die
seh ich also vorn was das gute ist wir
haben die gleichen Interessen
wir sehen bei der wir sind Weise wissen
so gesehen
zwar wieder ab so so müssen
Prozent also wenn man fünf Achsen
zusammen den flachen viel zusammen
und dann gibt es auch Kraft jetzt Hilfe
in Pressig im Weg und das ist einfach
sehr kurz
okay das Wort ja das kenne ich das Wort
weiter dabei wurde Galler eingesetzt
werden sollen da entdeckt worden seien
der Christ einfachste sehr gut also dass
muss
das ist mein
worden seit 4 Tagen ich erinnere mich
lebhaft ich glaube ich dass man das sei
und etwas heißen
ja okay
und Prozessende Saadiyat zweite geworden
ist das ist
wirklich gibt nicht nur Spannung
zwischen euch so diene auf keinen Fall
also wir wissen muss derweil wir stehen
im Finale und Alexander McQueen
und ja und wir haben uns fürs Finale
noch Gas gegeben haben sie erzielten
zusammen gelebt
unsere Bezahlung aller Zeiten mehr der
Erfolg lässt Horn Jahren ist sehr
schnell ersetzt als das Polizisten
nehmen auf
denn zeitgleich in den vergangenen
Jahren immer wieder gelungen den
Zeitgeist treffen uns auch persönlich
und das ist ein
sehr gut und es machte ihn noch stärker
einen gewissen Abstand halten
man weiß es genau der eine mag das dass
das wundersam the Frog müssen
ihr habt auch nicht immer das hat
Zukunft oder auf ihrer Fahrt hat das
mächtig ein er sagt dass es schlechter
geht seine Freundin hast und
nun gehe auf keinen Fall also
dass Menschen in diesen
wissen also
die wissen genau was Kohl wissen was
nicht gut ist sie sind also lesen Profis
die noch mit uns arbeiten und wissen
auch
«Das ist gut und das ist nicht gut
Richter
um St MLS wenn wird niemand sagen so
bleiben wir wollen jetzt dass sie nicht
das somit Saab scheint nämlich
es ist kein Mensch mehr machen weil wir
wollen das beste für dich und wenn sie
merken dass das beste für mich einfach
das ist dass ich mich zu ihr hingezogen
fühlt oder sich zivilen
Billen ein Mädchen auf
der Wälder zumindest mein Management
nicht sagen sowohl wenig
auf keinen Fall was hast du für Verdis
Mutter ich hab gehört haben sind
stänkert gegen dich
sie hat ihre Tochter verloren hat
wer also das war einfach
Wien die Presse sagt Phil Eisler
wann auch Sachen über mich ziemlich
schon durchdacht Anfang habe ich mal
dieses das gesagt das habe ich nie
gesagt und ich bin eigentlich immer
ziemlich sicher was ich sage
und ja dass das steckt man nicht immer
systematisch überwachen können
Rang ein der aus Unna nicht vorbei okay
sehr gut
gute Einstellung
Guldner der Sudan ist doch
DV dabei sei sie ganz Real keiner hätte
Australien sei stehe ich hier heute USA
abwarten
aber der Stimme verpasst haben»
erzählt aber ich finde sowas nicht
verbiegen lassen veröffentlicht wird
Pascal Eckhardt abermals aus sichtbar
ist
da ist das ja der Hammer ja ist er noch
keine Wahl
ja wir müssen kämpfen ich kann zum
Konzert und Prozent
das Wasser das Wiederaufleben
ausser Kraft Frage weshalb ein paar ein